in terms of college football what's this
common season gonna look like our friend
Brett McMurphy from stadium the stadium
college football insider put out a piece
today wrote a piece based on a poll that
he conducted of Football Bowl
Subdivision FBS athletic directors and
he joins us right here on the Rich Eisen
show to help reveal some of the results
how are you Brett I hope everybody in
your world happy healthy yes I actually
getting off track a little bit I
actually was five minutes from Big Cat
Rescue but everything is good here in
Tampa ok glad to hear that ok on that
front very good I got to get on that at
some point at some point yeah all right
so long story short Brett what did you
determine with your poll from your poll
yeah I reached out to all 130 athletic
directors within which 112 responded and
I basically said how optimistic are you
that a season would be played this year
and this was over the past week so I'm
sure the results have changed probably I
don't think so much for the better
probably for the worse but basically
about a about a fifth at the ADEs think
that there's a very real possibility we
may not have a football season this year
and it was an anonymous survey I told
him I would you know not reveal any of
their names or you know obviously could
quote them and those sort of things but
they all pretty much admitted that they
wanted to remain optimistic and so I
think if you know if I wasn't doing a
poll that would be released publicly I
think their outlook would be a lot
grimmer than what they gave me and what
the thoughts that they had if there is
no football season varied from will be
out of business it will be devastating
one ad just said simply we will be
blanked
they said that without the millions of
dollars of revenue from the football
programs and
involved with the football programs you
could see the Olympic non-revenue sports
being cut or even eliminated so what
does that all mean everybody's waiting
for the all-clear signal whatever that
is whatever that is so they can move
forward the problem is they don't know
when that will happen for instance Duke
has already canceled it's on campus on
campus summer session
I just think personally I think it's not
realistically realistic that when we get
to the fall then all these universities
will be okay with saying all right you
know what you thirty and forty thousand
student body kamalo from all over the
world come back to campus now it's safe
I don't think that's going to happen and
so if that doesn't happen then do you
move the football season back do you
play conference only games Kappa ladies
mentioned possibility of starting the
season in January I know how crazy that
sounds I would have laughed at that a
few weeks ago but that's a very real
possibility because he's ad know how
vital it is to get the revenue of
college football even if you play with
no fans at least you can recoup some of
the TV money but the biggest issue
though is the uncertainty of when they
get the all-clear and can move forward
is that going to be next week is that
going to be two months from now is that
going to be January
that's what nobody knows and that's what
frustrates everybody so much well I'll
tell you what Brett I would sign up for
an all-clear in January of 2021 I would
love that that would be that would be
awesome remarkable exciting just on
every facet let's game that out okay
let's say that that does happen you know
and I'm walk knocking on wood that
something like that is feasible why in
the world would somebody like Trevor
Lawrence suit up
for Clemson in January of 2021 when
there's a draft coming up that he's
definitely number one overall what what
in the world why would he be putting his
body arm and I has just one guy I mean
you could name name name all sorts of
big-time college football players and I
understand that you know then why would
he do it in September it's the same
thing he's still playing except for the
fact that there's a draft right around
the
whereas if he hurts himself in the
middle of October he's still a draftable
player that we all know about that
happens in March my gosh I can't imagine
how that could be possible
Brett you're right really seen that
obviously it's a different situation in
bowl games but you know that that would
be some of the consequences but bottom
line is whether Trevor Lawrence is a
starting quarterback at Clemson or
somebody else
Clemson would continue to play and they
in your scenario wits and a tease have
brought up we could have the Rose Bowl
in the Sugar Bowl host the semifinals
issue the national title game is in
Miami so we could be looking at a may
aim a Rose Bowl for the college football
semifinals in in your scenario that we
don't get started till January again how
many players may sit out because of what
you've brought up I'm sure there could
be a number but I'm guarantee there will
be enough to continue playing and again
if the ADEs can get a college football
season in in some way whether it's in
front of empty stands whether it's
conference only whether it's starting in
January on somehow someway they've got
to do it and you know look there's not
an athletic director on his face of the
earth or Conference Commissioner that in
their wildest dreams is ever set there
and said you know what we may not have a
college football season in 2020 so I
need to set aside this much money people
don't work that way obviously college
athletics doesn't because you would
never think we may not have a season but
now that that's a very real possibility
they're coming up with all these you
know possible ways to get these things
in but that you bring up a great point
and that would be one of the things you
know they would have to be considered
also you would basically be ending your
season in May and then you would be
starting you know practice for the next
season just two months later
Brett McMurphy Stadium college football
insider right here on the Rich Eisen
show so are you saying that the year of
eligibility that the NCAA just granted
seniors in spring sports that extra year
of eligibility that that good that piece
of good news that we heard that it's
entirely possible that if there is no
college football
season in 2020 there's no sport for them
to return to at their institution of
higher learning is that possible is what
you're saying to me Brett well no
because the spring sports is mostly the
baseball and and you know softball track
and field those sort of things Golf but
so those those athletes can return in
2021 but you know yeah who knows who
knows if we're gonna have any college
athletics next season I think we will
but again we no one knows when this
thing is going to end when when life
returns back to normal but as far as
football players there there can in the
fall semester sport there with the
basketball players the basketball
players were not extended an additional
year of eligibility so those guys that
were seniors or careers are over so yeah
so if it happened with footballs and
certainly they would i'm guessing they
would grant another year of eligibility
for football players if there was no
football season I guess I should have I
guess I guess I should have said there's
no program I mean that the that you're
saying that this the programs that are
funded by college football that we're
just extended ineligible I guess I guess
I should have said it that way that some
of these programs might not be around
anymore because the money to fund them
is gone is that right and that's what a
number of ADEs have said and again that
if they don't want to do this there's no
desire to do that but financially some
of these sports that used to be club
sports you know back when you and I are
on a college that are now you know
university sports maybe they return to
being club sports for a couple of years
maybe they return to being club sports
permanently I don't know that's that's
what these athletic directors and
ultimately the presidents of these
universities have to determine is that
what cost is it worth having these
sports that that don't quite frankly
they don't provide any revenue and they
cost the schools money to operate so
it's great when you got a football
machine
you know cranking out the money you can
pay for these things but then when
that's football money machine runs dry
there will be some consequences and you
bring up a great one last one for you
is there a failsafe date that you get
you gathered from the athletic directors
by which they need to make this decision
for 2020 in that rich there really isn't
I mean you know the coach is what I have
anywhere from four to eight weeks to get
ready for the season that obviously
would be a decision between all the
power conferences to determine what
works best for everybody collectively as
a group but I think they're they are
able to adjust those dates to get this
thing done I mean I think realistically
if if you and I think the last gasp
effort would be to play football season
in the spring people always wanted to
spring football there you go so I think
we would have to have a all clear like
you said bye-bye January because then
you could get kids on campus for the for
the spring semester that starts after
the Christmas holiday and then try to
get some kind of season in and then
you're obviously you get a basketball is
going to be starting late you're going
to be you know March Madness will be
going on during college football mean
there's a million different scenarios
and things that will impact each other
but rich I would say if we don't have an
all clear by by January then there's no
don't see any way we'll have a college
football season in 2020 whether it's in
the fall or in the spring Brett thanks
for the time appreciate it
but we'll chat soon hang in there that's
Brett McMurphy check out again his piece
on watch Stadium comm Stadium college
football insider you're in the Rich
Eisen show